little hope is the next game in the dark
pictures anthology series and like manna
Madden and supermassive previous hit
until dawn before it it's easy to look
at little hope and say oh it's the Salem
witch trials I got it but you'd be wrong
little hope the name of the town where
our intrepid cast find themselves is
actually based on Andover
according to supermassive games CEO Pete
Samuels the Andover witch trials are
often overlooked by the history books
but by the numbers and overs history is
the deadliest with more trials and
executions than anywhere else the Salem
witch trials as we know them were
actually split across two regions Salem
town the port city where the wealthier
families had established themselves and
Salem village where the poorer farming
families lived and worked in the year
1692 a hundred and fifty-two accusations
of witchcraft were brought forward
altogether Salem was home to 39
accusations but and over to the North
had 45 that's more than Salem town and
village combined and roughly a third of
all the witchcraft cases of 1692 the
first Andover resident to be accused was
Martha carrier who had only recently
moved to the town from Bellaire iike her
brother-in-law
Roger Toothaker was a physician back
home and he was accused of using magical
remedies his wife and daughter were
accused as well and eventually the blame
spread to Martha herself she was
executed not long after for the crime of
being related to someone who happened to
be accused and her family was far from
the only one shattered by the witch
trials
another Andover resident named Joseph
Ballard brought two girls up from Salem
to examine his sick wife Elizabeth the
girls said the cause of her illness was
witchcraft and just like that Ballard
pointed fingers and accused two local
women Mary Lacey and her daughter Mary
Jr the finger-pointing didn't stop there
Mary senior accused her own mother of
witchcraft
perhaps to deflect from herself and her
daughter but Mary jr. wound up
testifying against both her mother and
grandmother this betrayal of family this
desperation to put the attention on
someone else to save your own skin shows
the panic the people of Andover felt
it's this kind of irrationality that
intrigue
Pete's team at supermassive quote fear
was most prevalent in driving the
communities to do terrible things things
they wouldn't normally entertain the
main focus of all of our stories is
people in relationships and how those
relationships are stretched to extremes
you can witness these dynamics even in
the brief bit of little hope that we've
seen so far Andrew played by will
Poulter whom you might know from other
horror stories like black mare in
midsummer is the inquisitive type
wanting to learn more about these
horrifying events of the past in some
cases he'll even witness them in
Supernatural flashbacks the first of
these happens alongside Angela who's
much more skeptical one can imagine how
those opposing viewpoints can lead to
dramatic clashes further into the story
I definitely saw someone 100% sorry I
don't buy it
in the end nearly every accused witch in
Andover confessed and was executed only
a small few who flipped and worked for
the courts to seek out others suspected
fellow witches were spared but what
happened during the chaos leaves plenty
of room for supermassive to play around
take Arthur Miller's the crucible
possibly the most famous fictionalized
work about the Salem trials the play
does mention Andover and the trials
their only end when the people riot I'm
certainly looking forward to that sort
of dramatization with little hope the
game doesn't have a set launch date
beyond summer 2020 but keep your eye on
gamespot for more details as the release
gets closer
[Music]
you